Okay, let's let's let's do this again.
In whostead,
>> bro. This is no answer again.
It's
the
>> Why would God need to die in order for
us to be saved?
>> Sure. Because
>> you have a video on this, right?
>> Yeah, I do. Yeah. So, the Bible says
that, you know, the wage of sin is
death. The price of sin is death. That's
God's law. And so God is just so
that on video.
>> You got that on video.
>> Video
was respectful.
>> He did. He said, "Can I interject?"
That's That's a respectful way. No, no,
no, no. Go ahead. Go ahead. Okay. There
have been even when you look at previous
scriptures, there have been people who
have had their sins forgiven for them by
making sacrifices that were not of blood
or performing other actions. Like for
example, Elijah was forgiven of his sins
by kissing a burning coal in the Old
Testament.
>> No, no, no.
>> Yes, it is a vision that he's having.
Yes.
>> You're you're talking about you're
talking about Isaiah, but the context is
different. But go but go ahead.
>> I believe it was it's in Isaiah, but it
is Elijah's.
>> No, it's Isaiah, brother.
>> Yeah. Isaiah chapter 6 I stand I'm
saying okay I stand corrected I stand
correct
>> but your point still stands that you
know Isaiah he his his cold touched his
lips which cleansed his mouth purified
his mouth of the sins
>> not even just him other people before
also would make sacrifices of fruit in
order for the forgiveness of their sin
as well or nothing is dying in that
sense so why must you have death in
order to
>> yeah so notice those those sacrifices
were because those people couldn't
afford bulls and goats So God made
exceptions for them that they since they
cannot sacrifice a bull or a lamb. What
you have, let's say the next step would
be birds. If you don't have birds, then
the next step would be uh uh I think
it's like frankincense or some type of
plants or something like that, right?
Your herbs. And so he's meeting you
where you are, giving you exceptions,
but those are exceptions to the rule.
You understand? And so with those
exceptions to the rule, they don't cover
them completely. Like that's just a
temporary covering. It doesn't purify
their sin. And so this is why the true
and final sacrifice had to come to
purify sin for all time. To cover sin
for all time.
>> Quiet question. You believe God is
capable of all things that God is
almighty.
>> Yes.
>> You believe that God is allseeing and
all knowing?
>> Would God be able to forgive you of his
of your sins if you so wanted?
>> Let me answer this. Okay. So the reason
why I would say no to this would be
because God is just as well. So you
would you and I agree with that God
can't contradict his character, right?
>> Okay. So like so for example, God can't
lie. He's true. He's truthful. He is
truth. Do you believe God can lie?
>> Right. I don't either. Um God can't fail
or contradict himself in any way, right?
He's ever living, ever successful.
>> Yeah. Sure. So in regards to this, you
have God who is just. So he can't just
let sin go un undelt with. So so he has
to deal with sin which is death. So but
he loves you. He's also merciful. So
instead of taking your life he comes
takes on humanity represents mankind for
us because we can't represent ourselves
and he dies the death that we should
die.
>> May I ask you a question? How is it just
for Jesus who is a sinless innocent man
who is a beloved and esteemed prophet of
God and you would say he's more than
that but let's say prophet of God to be
killed for other people's sins that he
is not associated with. Should you refer
your own for forgiveness of your own
sins? You should ask God your own self
and take your own actions. For example,
you were mentioning the sacrifices. All
those sacrifices were done by those
people. Then where they have to
sacrifice bulls or rams or
Isaiah where he had to kiss the poor
you're not taking any action to be
forgiven. It's Jesus you try to actually
not. So so for example when they would
sacri when they would give their their
herbs and incense. They're giving the
herb and incense to be sacrificed not
themselves. Right.
>> They're giving the ox and the lamb to be
sacrificed not themselves. Right. Yeah,
but they're still a sacrifice of giving
the sacrifice and trusting in God's
forgiveness, right? giving Jesus to be
sacrificed. Well, well, this so the
thing God gave him God gave him the
father gave him to be sacrificed and so
he's the one who offered look there's
there's a beautiful example of this
where um watch this uh you know the
story where God told Abraham to
sacrifice his son right okay Isaac
>> right right so nonetheless so just just
biblically right just in our paradigm
the Bible says it's Isaac right um the
the the chosen son and so in getting
ready to
>> Yeah, that that's that means he's the
special one, right? So,
>> yeah. Well, yeah, that's that means he's
special. He's preeminent over Ishmael in
this just let's stick to the point. So,
in the paradigm, you have Abraham who's
commanded that sacrifice Isaac.
>> But now, instead of sacrificing Isaac,
God steps in. Abra uh uh Isaac asks,
"Where's the where's the lamb? Where's
the sacrifice?" Abraham says, "God will
provide the sacrifice."
So notice here how God Abraham says God
will provide the sacrifice and what does
God do? He provides a lamb in the thorn
bush.
>> Right? So we have examples throughout
where God gives the sacrifice. He offers
the sacrifice on our behalf. This is
what he did with the son. The son was
the lamb that was given in our place. So
instead of us being put on that altar,
it's Christ himself as the lamb being
put on the altar of God.
>> Do you believe that this was also from
forgiving just people
>> every everyone. Yes.
>> So this would mean that even people
sacrificed in the past were going to
hell and had been in hell up until
Jesus.
>> Not hell. Not hell, but they were in the
realm of the dead. Hell is a different
place. The the the realm of the dead or
sha is what the Hebrew calls it is where
the people or the righteous people would
go uh when they die. They wouldn't go to
paradise yet. They wouldn't go to heaven
yet. It's another place is called is
called Abraham's bosom. That's another
name for it. Usually when I I don't know
if you said this person, but I've spoken
to other Christians and they would have
told me that Jesus went to hell to
rescue the souls from there and then
I'll be incorrect. The correct place
would be sha or Hades, the realm of the
dead. Hell is the hell is Greek
mythology.
>> Well, no. Hades is just a Greek word for
the realm of the dead. So in Greek
mythology, they'll take their concept of
Hades to be something. In you know the
Bible, Hades is the god of death.
>> Oh yeah, that's that's a different
concept. Hades is just the word for the
realm of the dead in the Greek.
>> Yeah. So, so just to ask a question.
>> Yeah. So, so just to just to finish
this. So, biblically you have God who
offers the sacrifice so that we can be
saved to appease his justice and his and
he also is able to appease his mercy and
love by offering a sacrifice in our
place.
>> Would it not be just Well, here's the
thing though. It's still you still did
not
know.
>> Yeah. It's not It's not me. You're
right.
>> But even with the many of the people
passed, they still have to go retrieve a
bowl. They'd still go retrieve a cow or
a ram or something like that. Sure,
maybe not for Abraham, but Abraham still
had to perform the sacrifice of the ram.
You didn't have to do anything.
>> But who offered?
>> It was offered by God, but you didn't do
anything for the sacrifice.
>> I mean, that's that's that's the point.
>> The sacrifice was done before you were
born. Abraham still had to perform the
sacrifice.
>> But see see this this is the point. This
is the point. The point of the gospel is
is that we don't do anything to be
saved. It's not upon us. So that for
example, the Bible says,
>> well, it's not because it says like
there's nothing we can do to earn God's
mercy.
>> What do you mean? Cuz he's a for
example, let me get God is the most
merciful.
>> Let me give you an example. Okay. So
yes, with God being most merciful, but
he's also just, you can't forget that
he's merciful. He's also just. So for
example, let's let's even bring it down
to even our level. Would you Right.
Exactly. with a with a just judge. Let's
say I robbed the bank. I'm caught on
camera. Got the bag in my car, bro. I
robbed the bank. I'm caught, right? Um
but on my court date, I meet the judge.
I say, "Judge, yes, that's me. But I'm
genuinely sorry. Please just let me go
forgive me. I I will never do this
again. I'm crying and I'm sincere. I'm
genuine. I will never do this again.
Please let me go. Forgive me." This once
again,
>> will if that judge is if that judge is
just, would he let me go?
>> Counter point. What if you uh the cost
is returning the money you stole and
paying for the damages you did while
breaking into the bank?
>> Let's see. Will the judge let me go
unpunished?
>> Well, we live in a system where you
would do a case for years.
>> So, a just judge would lock me up,
right?
>> American
separate.
>> Well, that's that's what I'm that's what
I'm asking you. Would a just judge
punishment?
You would have to here's the thing. If
you returned the items that you stole
and you uh paid for the cost of raking
>> still theft,
>> but you rectified it.
>> No, I didn't. I got I got caught with
it.
>> You gave back the
>> I didn't I didn't rectify anything.
>> No, I'm saying you paid for the cost of
you're you're changing the analogy in
the in the analogy bankrupt. No, no,
it's an same analogy.
>> No, but you're you're adding
stipulations
$50,000. Will will the I I just want to
brother I just want to know will the
judge if will the judge if he's just let
me go if I'm caught red-handed for
robbing the bank
>> in America they would rule over the US
law constitution or you would be punish
or you would be punished for that crime
>> would that be just
>> that's a separate argument
>> no that is the argument what would the
judge be just for punishing me for for
the crime of theft
>> how about this what if the judge what if
the judge killed his own son instead of
you What? What? We're getting this in a
second. But will the judge be just if he
punished me for my crime?
>> In order, we know what argument you're
going to. Let's say yes. The second
argument.
>> Okay. So then he would be unjust if he
just forgave my crime and let me go
scotfree, right?
>> If he didn't have to pay back anything.
>> Yeah. Scott free. He just forgave me.
>> He didn't have to pay back anything. I
would say that's unfree.
>> Scot free. That's okay. I agree. So So
we understood that a judge that is
judging would be unjust if he just lets
crime go under the rug without dealing
with the crime, without punishing the
crime in some way. Right? Okay. So with
God, he because he's just, he's
infinitely more just than an earthly
judge. So this means that if if even an
earthly judge won't just let crime go,
even the holy judge of the heavens and
earth can't just let sin go because he's
just sin is just let go.
>> That's what you're saying.
>> No, no. If you commit sins that are
crimes, like for example, theft or
murder, there are worldly punishments
for those crime for those actions.
>> Is that a godly punishment?
>> It's ordained by God. Yes.
>> Oh, so it's okay. So or is jail time is
ordained by God? Like that's what God
like said. Hey,
>> cuz God never wrote the jail. That's
what I'm saying. So, what is the what is
God's How does God deal with the sin?
>> It I'm saying I'm saying I'm saying from
the holy book,
>> it says hell.
>> It says hell.
>> Not just not hell. It also says if you
commit murder then the crime the
likeness for it is your own head, right?
>> Yeah. If you commit adultery, you get
whipped. If you steal, you might you
have to pay back,
>> right? So, if so, watch this. Let's say
in any other
>> just forgiven for saying oh I want to
forgive you take actions in order to be
forgiven and you'll still be punished so
>> exactly so the Quran
>> you are the one who's facing them
>> I'll wait till you finish did you finish
saying you are the one who's facing them
not so
>> yeah so focusing on the point the point
is you asked why can't God just forgive
your sins if he's all powerful and
capable to do all things.
>> Why can't God just let you go? So now
you you're we're at the point where you
agree with me that God can't just let
you go without punishment, right?
>> And the thing is you're not the one
being punished.
>> That's not the question.
>> But you agree that there has to be a
punishment, right?
>> You should serve the punishment.
>> Okay. So now watch this. So you and I
agree that sin cannot just be swept
under the rug. It has to be dealt with,
right?
>> Okay. So now let's let's stop here. Now,
your problem is is someone else taking
on the sin for you or taking on that
punishment for you. That's your problem.
You think that that's not fair. Okay?
So, this is what I'm going to say to
you. Okay? I'm going to I'm going to say
this.
>> With this being said, you know, um uh
fines being paid, like bail amount,
someone can bail someone out, right?
Like if someone commits a crime
depending on what the crime is, not all
crimes, but so let's say a particular
crime that it has available bail.
There's a particular crime and so you
commit the crime. However, if you pay
the bail fine, you could be let go.
>> Right now, you're going to say if
someone else pays,
here's the thing.
>> Answer that and then explain.
>> Well, actually, I will answer it. It's
not equivalent to the same of believing
that you're destined for eternal
hellfire because of a sin you didn't
commit. We're not talking about the type
of punishment you get. I'm asking is it
just if someone steps in and pays the
fine for you for the crime you did if
they're okay with doing so and I agree
with it then excellent. So here's the
point. The gospel teaches that Christ
himself is okay and did it on purpose.
He says look that he doesn't say that.
That's that's the only argument they
use. It never says that they switch.
>> Thanks for the question.
Okay.
>> Well, yeah. I want to I want to give you
some verses. This is chap Mark 10:18.
Jesus says that the son of man did not
come to serve uh to be served, but he
came to serve and give his life as a
ransom for many. In John 12, he says,
"My heart," cuz his crucifixion is
approaching. He says that my heart is
troubled, but what shall I say? Father,
save me for the from this hour. But it's
for it's for this hour that I came. So
Jesus says, "I came here for this
reason, right? He was willingly came and
gave his life for us." So he was okay
with paying the fine on our behalf. And
guess what? All we have to do is be okay
with it as well and accept the payment
that he gave. And that's the gospel
message.
>> I'd like to say two.
>> Sure.
>> My question.
>> Okay.
>> Well, I'm continuing
>> life. Are we still good like with
battery and everything?
>> Okay. I'm continuing the same
conversation. The another aspect of this
that has been missed that we haven't
really been talking about was that the
sin that you're being punished for you
was not committed by you.
>> You're being punished for the sin of
Adam and Eve.
>> No, you believe that you're destined to
hellfire.
>> No, brother. Just just ask me what I
believe. That's not what I believe.
>> Okay. So, so the Bible says that death
comes to all men cuz all men sin.
>> So, do you not believe in original sin,
Avery?
>> Yeah, but you have a you have a
misconception of what original sin is.
Original sin isn't that I'm guilty of
what Adam did. Original sin is the
concept that's because of Adam's sin, we
now after Adam are born with a sinful
nature. Not that I'm born guilty of him.
>> Why am why must I be born with a sinful
nature because of a sin that was
committed in the world.
>> Because just like how if a king falls,
the kingdom falls. If a king wastes the
money of the kingdom, then the citizens
become poor. So there's a consequence
for the head's actions. The Adam was
Adam was the head. Listen, listen,
brother. You got to listen.
>> Adam is the head of was the head of
humanity. So his actions bears
consequences to those who he's supposed
to be head over, which is us.
>> Sure. We have a$100 gift card. I wasn't
alive at that time. If you're living in
a kingdom that time,
you're still around for those effects. I
am many not only am I far separated from
it, I am not bear any responsibility of
it either. Furthermore,
furthermore, the consequence is not
being impoverished or struggling with
other aspects. The consequence is
eternal health.
>> No. So again, just saying it's just
saying, "Oh, well, this punishment is
not as bad." That's not the point. The
point is is punishment and consequence.
Please listen. The p the the
conversation is about consequence
period. So if you have, for example,
let's say the kingdom falls, that means
the kingdom falls, which means that all
of the citizens will be affected by it,
a bankruptcy in the in the kingdom.
Someone who isn't born yet will now be
born, let's say they're born a year
after the kingdom has fallen into
bankruptcy. So wait, so now the person
born is being born into poverty because
of the consequences of the king, right?
So you don't wait, let me let me finish,
brother.
>> The king commits.
>> Come on, brother.
himself. Do other people bear that
action?
>> They bear the consequence.
>> The king commits adultery, do I bear the
consequence?
>> It depends on the action. So, for
example, if the king goes and uh betrays
a country, betrays another kingdom that
he's supposed to be allied with, right?
So, betrayal, that's a sin. If he goes
and betrays and lies and breaks a
covenant with another kingdom, well,
hold on.
If will will his betrayal of that
kingdom affect the citizens that's
within his own kingdom?
>> Exactly.
>> How is that different?
>> Adam is only against his own self.
>> No, it's not just it's so Adam Adam
listen
against God and this sin affects God.
Let me finish. Adam s
>> absolutely that's what sin is.
>> You s you're not letting me finish. This
is you're showing me you're not
listening. You're not letting me finish.
making that up
>> yet. While I'm talking to him, you're
making that up.
>> No, it's not. I want you to interrupt
it. Let me finish my point so that you
if you listen, if you listen, you'll get
the point. Okay. So, Adam's sin against
God, that's what sin is. Sin against
God, falling in of disobeying God's
commands. Sin of Adam sin against God,
the consequences befail us as well. You
understand? So if you don't get the
concept even though you say you're
conceding to all the examples I'm giving
you. You're saying yes a kingdom a king
doing this consequences goes to his uh
his uh his uh citizens. This happens a
president does this citizens are
affected so to say that
>> no it's not different.
>> Yes it is according to who?
>> Because the situations are different.
Avery, Adam eating an apple that he was
told not to eat is not the same as a
president just betraying somebody
because they're
>> But who are you to say? How how do you
know the effect of Adam who's the head
of humanity?
>> Say I'm interrupting you and now you
interrupt me. Go ahead.
>> And I'm saying those the likeness is not
the same. Adam is committing this
against his own disobeying directly by
God not to do this. This sin only
affects him because he's the only one
there committing it and there's no one
else directly around him. Right? who is
the father of Joseph,
>> right? So that should not be upon people
going after. If you live in a nation,
even still, you're not at fault for the
nation coming.
So if you go to Matthew, it says the
father.
If I'm a citizen of the country and the
leader makes a horrible decision like
breaking the lines, I'm not at fault for
that decision. So it's unjust for me to
bear the result because we had an unjust
ruler. But you said God is just. So the
likeness of these two things are not the
same.
>> Okay. So this is demonstrating that
you're not listening to me, brother.
>> I am.
>> Okay. Did I say that I'm responsible for
what Adam did or did I say I'm reaping
the consequence of what Adam did?
>> And I'm saying it's unjust.
>> What What did I say? Like what did I
say?
>> You said a second.
>> Okay. So So notice I let you speak and I
heard you and then you straw what I said
by saying that it's not fair for us to
be punished uh and be guilty for what
Adam did. That's not my position.
>> Oh yeah, you did. But you just did. So
no. Oh, let me say it again. We are not
guilty of what Adam did, but what Adam
did reaps consequences on his on the on
his successors. Just like you conceded
that the actions of a king will have
consequences on his citizens. So if you
say sure, then you're conceding that
it's logical and it makes sense that
Adam as the head of humanity, his
actions would have consequences, whether
beneficial or whether detrimental to
those who succeed him. If you have a if
if you're saying that, oh no, this
doesn't work here, but it works here.
You have to show me that like the the
symmetry breaker cuz you're being
inconsistent.
>> The difference is that you're saying
human beings deserve hell.
>> That we deserve.
>> Why? Why do I think human beings deserve
hell? position
human beings that human beings are
deserving of because of Adam's sin born
with a sinful nature because of it.
>> So, so let me can you just ask me what I
believe?
>> Sure.
>> What do you believe?
>> So, thank you for asking me. I
appreciate it.
>> I believe that humans are deserving of
hell because each human being is uh
guilty of sin
>> because you lie, I lie, somebody else
lie or steals or whatever sin they
break, they they commit. because they
sin, they're deserving of hell. No man
is perfect and without sin except
Christ. So that's why we are deserving
of hell. I'm not deserving of hell
because Adam ate a fruit that he wasn't
supposed to eat. I'm deserving of hell
because in my sinful nature after
because of the consequence of what Adam
did, I chose to sin as well against God.
I'm more inclined to sin instead of
inclined to obey. I'm inclined to rebel
instead of inclined to be in line with
God. That's the nature that I have. So
because of my actions, I'm deserving of
hell.
>> Understand?
>> Yeah, I understand your position. I have
two questions for you. The first is why
why must the nature of the human being
changed because Adam committed the sin?
>> Because Adam was given the head of
humanity. The Bible says that God gave
him rulership over the earth. So
dominion over the earth. He's supposed
to take care of it. and the successors.
So, Adam is in a spiritual like he's
he's living a spiritual life and
physical life. Spiritually connected
with God. When Adam severs that
connection with God, it severs it for
humanity. So now death has entered enter
the realm and sin has entered the realm
because Adam broke that connection of
God and now we're spiritually dead
instead of being spiritually alive.
>> Adam asked God for forgiveness. Where
did you go?
>> It's possible. It's possible. Well, no.
I don't I we don't believe he was sent.
We believe all this happened on earth.
>> Is that one of the cases?
>> You believe all this happened on earth?
>> Yeah. The Garden of Eden in the Bible is
on earth.
>> Okay.
>> You can look into
>> So, do you believe that he asked for
forgiveness afterwards?
>> There's there's no explicit statement,
but I I believe that you
>> Yeah, I I think so. I think that
>> he was not forgiven then.
>> Yeah, he was.
>> Okay. So, God can forgive Adam because
he asked for forgiveness. Why can he not
forgive any of us because we ask for
>> Well, you're you're missing a part
again. the the Adams. Can I answer you?
>> Sure.
>> Okay. So, the very the very first for
for example um what happened? Do are you
familiar with the story of what what God
did once before he kicked Adam and Eve
out of the garden in the Bible? Um what
God did for them?
>> Uh you may say a story.
>> Okay. So, he killed an animal for them.
He killed animals for them and then used
the the animal's skin. Used the animal
skin. Sound like something fell. used
the animal skin to cover Adam and Eve's
nakedness. So, it's in the Garden of
Eden that we get the first sacrifice
where guess who's the first one who
offers the sacrifice and kills an animal
on Adam and Eve's behalf? It's God. So,
still you have a a sacrifice given and
offered not by man but by God himself on
their behalf. Yeah, the issue is you're
I mean I'm not going to
all this.
>> Of course, you're asking me a biblical
narrative.
>> But this is also saying that the concept
of God being all knowing, all all
powerful, just, and that you would do
this is because the Bible says so.
>> Well, I think it's not just cuz the
Bible says so. It's that the Bible shows
why this is necessary. where where God
is is both loving and merciful and he's
just at the same time. Within Islam, you
don't have where God's justice and mercy
can co can coincide. You have where
look, you have where Allah is merciful.
He forgives your sins, but sin isn't
dealt with. Sin is swept under the rug.
>> No, there is justice absolutely with
sin. If you commit a sin, there are not
only worldly punishments, but you can
also accumulate sins and you may
eventually go to hell for those, right?
>> You you you know how you're so against
like this idea of someone else taking on
someone else's sins in Islam. It teaches
that Jews and Christians take the sins
of Muslims.
>> So it is you read regarding this. This
is talking about Jews and Christians who
have committed wrong against
>> what what taps
are you referring to hadith?
>> Yeah. So what taps are you talking
about? You're talking about
>> might be even I don't know off the top
of my head for the taps itself.
>> Yeah, maybe even as well. You're saying?
>> Yeah. I mean, I was saying there's a few
I don't know if I don't know if the top
>> immi says that they this is happening to
them because they deserve it because of
their disbelief as Jews and Christians.
That's what I Ni says.
Let me show you the hadith
>> that even in Islam you have this idea of
someone else taking on the sins of
another
>> i.e. us Jews and Christians
Muslim
>> 2767
>> B
>> A and B
>> okay well just Ei either one. So it says
uh you're reading B or A. Which one are
you reading?
>> Are you talking about we're talking
about on the day of judgment Allah will
provide for every Muslim, a Jew or
Christian? That one.
>> Yeah. And say uh that is your rescue
from hellfire.
>> Right. So the hadith, did you see it?
You saw. So the hadith is teaching that
Jews and Christians are taking on the
sins of Muslims. We're we're saving you
from hellfire.
So like I said
connection
this say that this is here is alive
and Christian
open
>> because Islam does say that anyone who
commits a wrong against another will
bear some of their sins
committed wrong against
>> no so the Quran doesn't say that the
Quran says if you mislead someone then
you'll bear some of their sins not if
you do wrong to them. It doesn't I'm not
just talking about as well.
>> Where does the hadith say that?
>> If you wrong somebody maybe I haven't
seen that before.
>> But notice not notice how you're
>> Yeah. Nice talking to you. But but
notice how you're giving a you're
justifying you're justifying someone
taking on the sins of another. So you're
okay with it.
>> But you have a problem when when it
comes to Christianity. That is your
burden.
>> But it's not my burden anymore cuz I'm
taking on on No, I'm taking on your sin.
>> You're missing the point, Avery.
>> I'm taking on your s wrong if I wrong
you and you take some of my sins. I am
deserving of that wronging you.
>> But when you someone else who's burning
your sins that didn't do any wrong
against you, didn't commit any,
>> you know, it doesn't say anything about
doing wrong, brother.
It says on the day of resurrection in
order to save the Muslims from hellfire,
Allah is going to place in theirstead
you a Christian. So we're taking on your
sins because we're Jews and Christians.
>> Give me a second.
>> That's not possible.
>> You're making you're trying to
rationalize that's impossible.
>> Okay. If I say Muhammad
decided that he was a prophet and that
he went to Mecca, he went to all these
things. If I don't include something
that happened in between those points,
that says contradiction. That's not
that's not the same thing. That's like
saying the prophet went to Mecca and
another story saying he went to Medina.
>> It's two completely different things.
It's just like it's just like the father
scenario that you just mentioned where
there's two different fathers. You're
trying to say that Eli and Joseph are
the same person.
>> It's not
>> it's not it's two completely different
things. They're not relevant.
>> Okay. Say Moham and go to Mecca.
>> Yeah. Sometimes. Yes.
>> Did he go to Medina
>> at two different points?
>> Is that a contradiction?
>> But but this is okay. Can can someone
die? Can someone die more than once?
>> More than once.
>> Okay. So how Okay. So how is saying
someone how is how is it related to
someone doing two different things we're
still going to die two different ways
you only die if I die someone shoot me
in the head
told me that's where it said
this is right now
said that
>> was he was he anyone who's done an act
of injustice against his brothers honor
or anything else ask if he did this
before when he either did not or did him
if he has done good deeds equal to the
wrongdoings or rejected but He has done
no good deeds. He will be made to bear
the evil deeds of one who is wrong in
the same portion. So if you commit wrong
against someone if you commit wrong
against somebody they can take your sins
from the on the
that's fine and all but that's a
different that's a different context
here. So you're so look
and they're looking at this and they
obviously studied a lot and they
>> they there's no connection with this and
that
>> I believe in one. It says that says if
you wronged your brother.
>> Yeah.
>> Jews and Christians are not your
brothers.
>> God brother is just referring to
>> someone. No, it's referring to someone
in your faith.
>> Yeah. For here it's your faith. So
that's not a Jew or Christian. You wrong
against me and the same would follow.
And this is the same
thing.
If you if you have someone who's a
disbeliever and they wrong you and they
do not seek your forgiveness, they do
not ask for anything, some of your sins
will be transferred to them. So, but so
what but this is my problem. My problem
is is that you're you're trying to
overexlain or add in to hadith where
stuff doesn't say. Notice the context
here says if your listen the context
says if your brother wrongs you or you
wrong a brother then this is what
happened. A Jew and a Christian is not
your brother. Right.
>> Are you a scholar of a son?
>> Uh I'm just about I'm a shake myself.
Yeah.
>> You speak just just I I don't have to.
I'm an English shake. Baby
>> English. Yeah.
How can you be an English? How can you
be a shake is just a shake is just a
person of knowledge, right?
>> Yeah. How can you be knowledgeable if
you can't read a book?
>> I can. I read the Quran. That's why I
know so much.
>> That's why that's why I know so much.
>> You never read it before in your life?
>> Yes, I read the whole Quran. What are
you talking about? That's why I know
more than most most Muslims.
>> Many
of you
going through layers of translation.
>> Say that again. If a bunch of you are
still reading a book even if it's going
through layers of translation, not every
and words only. So, so forgive me
because it sounds like you're an
appealing to authority and that for all
the Muslims who don't speak Arabic are
not who are only English speakers who
only read the Quran in English, they're
not even really really reading the
Quran. Is that right?
>> Unless they're reading a translation of
the Quran,
>> right? So, they're not really reading
the Quran.
>> Poor English
is why the Quran. So, so, so
unfortunately for these people, so for
these English Muslims who don't know a
lick of Arabic, who only know the Quran
from the English translation, they're
reading, they're reading the meaning of,
>> right? So, they're not really reading
the Quran.
>> They're not reading the They might have
to read the text, but they're reading
the meaning of the Quran.
>> So, they're not really reading the
Quran. Correct.
>> And you're not reading the Wait, hold
on. Just answer yes or no.
>> Sure. They're not reading the text of
the Quran. They're reading it. So, so
unfortun but they think they're reading
the Quran. They're reading it meaning.
>> So someone needs to tell them understand
from it meaning but there's still stuff
that they may miss because it's a
translation.
>> So I can so I can get the understanding
of the Quran from the translation.
>> Translation
so so far I'm good which is why it's a
standard
right it's a standard for all messiah
that there have to know Arabic
>> according to what
>> it's considered a standard in Islam.
Where where is that written?
You how you cannot pass any test of or
um regard or understanding of the Quran
>> based on what
>> or fifth if you don't read Arabic
>> based on what it's required
>> based on what
>> where where is it written that that's a
requirement to be a shake
>> what do you wait hold on do you think
any
that says
>> anyway that's that's besides the point
of it but go ahead bro
>> this was this was to his point I still
have my question I want to ask you
that's why I came there's a verse in the
Quran that says It's only only those who
truly hear Allah from the scholar.
>> Sure. Yeah. Yeah. They said nothing
about knowing Arabic. So my point is
that Jews and Christians are subject our
heroes save you from your sins.
>> No, just let let me land this. So if
you're going to be consistent and say
that there's a problem, it's unjust for
someone else to take the sins of
another, then you have to drop Islam and
condemn Islam for teaching that someone
else, a Jew and a Christian, is going to
take your sins. You have to condemn it.
And I've addressed this and I've said
this will be the
scholars have said that this is in
reference to Jewish
wrongs against Muslim
>> and and so so what and there's other
that have a different opinion like Imam
Nawi who says that they deserve this
because they're Jews and Christians
because of their kufar
>> which is why we look at what the
majority scholars say.
>> Yeah. So what is the majority of what
they say
>> that that the Jews and the Christians
reference your
>> how do how do you know how do you know
that that's the consensus?
Yeah. Well, how do you know that? That's
the consensus regarding this hadith that
it's because the Jews and Christians.
>> Yeah. Well, this is important because he
was really going hard about it being it
being unjust for God to put someone
else's sins on on Jesus on someone else.
So, I'm showing him that he has this
problem in Islam, but he's now
justifying it. So, I'm showing this
inconsistency.
>> You are you're saying it's okay because
they done wrong to the Jew to the
Muslims.
>> It's not bearing.
>> So, that's justification. But you're not
bearing a burden anymore if you
committed wrong. Now it is your burden.
>> No, brother. It says it says commit
wrong. No, let me ask. I commit wrong
against you and you take from my sin.
If I commit wrong against you and I take
from your day of judgment or have I been
wronged. So if you you're saying if you
wrong me and then you take some of my
sins because you wronged me.
>> So those sins Yes. Those sins are not
your sins. Right. I wronged you.
>> Okay. No worries. Look, brother. I'm not
arguing against this that's what I'm
saying. I'm not brother. Hold on.
Right. So, I'm not I'm not arguing
against your understanding. My point is
the inconsistency. You're justifying a
situation where you can take on the sin
of another.
>> And I am saying that that is not the
same as unjustly someone's burden.
>> Where do you get unjustly from? Where do
you get unjustly from? It's it's if if
somebody else committed a sin that I did
not commit. Your whole point was that's
wrong to bear that sin. But now you're
saying it's okay if I wrong that person.
That's so I got the point.
>> If I wrong you, if I wrong you. No, no,
no.
>> If I wrong you, right? If I steal from
you, if I uh
>> let's say steal, let's let's say you say
you steal from me. Let's say I steal
from you. I never face any I never face
any trial in this world and uh you never
forgive me. Right? There should be some
justification for that. Right?
>> Which would be
>> which would be I give you some of my
good deeds or I take from your sins as a
compensation as a punishment for the
action that I
>> So you're going to be I got you. So
you're going to be punished for someone
else's sins, right?
>> No. I'm being punished for my theft from
you.
>> No listen
you're not you're not hearing me. I
stole from you. I would never have to
bear those sins.
>> Bear who sins?
>> So those So you're bearing sins that are
not yours, right?
>> Because I stole from you, they become
>> No worries. Forget the reason. So you're
so so so my brothers.
>> No, let's go with your all of that. So
you're justifying taking on the sin of
someone else, right?
>> Please don't interrupt the conversation.
We're doing good.
>> Who's just He's justifying it.
>> Yes.
>> If he's justifying it, he's wrong.
>> I want to be first and last.
>> Tell him that. What versions
>> talking about Jews bearing the
>> worship?
I was telling you,
>> you don't want to talk about that, bro.
You don't want me to bring that up, bro.
>> Worship.
>> You don't want me to bring that up, bro.
Have you looked at the context?
>> Can they be worshiped?
>> Hold on. Before I even ask you, have you
looked at the context? Do you really
believe that according to Muslims,
you're going to die for my sins? And
that's all I'm saying.
>> That's what that's what the hadith says.
So this does any Muslims?
I don't understand why.
>> Yeah, that's what he says.
>> All right, let's do it. Let's read it
again.
>> No Muslim would die. No Muslim would
die, but Allah would admit in hisstead a
Jew or a Christian in hellfire. So who's
dying for the who's dying for the
Muslims?
>> That's amazing. Let's talk about it.
>> According according to Muhammad, who's
dying for the Muslims?
>> Let's talk about it right now. Let me
show you this. Do you mind answering
>> I'm literally on topic right now
this
answering your question this hadith
right here if you look at it in the
context of other hadith it's just
talking about how there will be people
be shown their place in paradise shown
their place in hellfire and everyone has
a place in paradise in hellire places
the places Jews and Christians because
they disobeyed God they will go to
hellfire the Muslims will inherit their
places.
>> So whose whose place is the hellfire?
Can I speak the prophet was the prophet
just that's why you have other hadith
that says none will enter paradise but
he'll be shown his place and and he'll
be shown place in the hellfire and in
Jenna or and in paradise right in
another hadith he says there's no one
among you except he has two abs right
and Allah says those are the inheritors
now with that specific because you tried
to be slick with it logic with that
specific scholars have said that this
hadith is weak because it was by no they
They didn't. No, they didn't. No, that's
not the That's not the narration. You're
not even talking about the Hadith
narration. I'm talking about
>> No, I'm talking about B.
No, it's not. No, it's not. These are
two different hadith narrations. This
shows you guys don't even know how
works. These are these are literally
>> I just scrolled up to A. I just scrolled
up to A. So calm down before you
embarrass yourself. So this is B. Is
this week?
>> Yes.
>> Show me where it's this week.
>> I'll show you right now.
>> Yeah. Eight narrators. Narrator. Show me
that this one is weak.
>> Please.
>> Or do you want do you know?
>> Show me that this one is weak.
>> I'll show you. I'll show you.
>> Eight narrators. They said they did it
without this wording and only one from
which wording
>> the wording that you're read Muslim.
Which
>> one said in the he says there are other
indicate the wording married by im
Muslim are we? Which one? I tell you
another one. This one.
>> No. See no. So this this is the
deceptive thing. Hold on. I just let you
speak. It's my turn. So this is this is
what is this is what the problem is.
You're not even showing the same hadith
I'm talking about. So you don't even you
don't is this the same hadith?
>> What what letter is that?
>> Sorry. What letter is that?
>> 267 A and B.
>> Okay. What is No, it's See, now look
notice what he did. 267 A and B are like
the same. No, they're not. Do is this
the same narration?
>> Please read it.
>> Can we read the wording?
>> Yeah. Is this the same narration?
>> Let's read the wording.
>> Yeah, go ahead. Read it. when it will be
Oh my god, he's about to go. Go ahead.
>> Why are you on A again? Do you know
that?
>> Because we're showing the difference. So
read A.
>> Okay, I have A and A. There's B.
>> Oh, you have A already?
>> Yes. Okay, good. Read it. Muslim would
die, but Allah would admit in hisstead a
Jew or Christian.
>> That's B.
>> Yes.
>> Okay. What does A say?
>> When it will be on the day, Allah
delivered to every Muslim a Jew or
Christian and say rescue from the
hellfire.
>> All right. So is this is that a
different res is that a different
narration?
>> Look, A and B A and B are literally it's
like the exact same.
>> It's the you're right. It's the It's the
same topic, but it's a different
narration. Do you understand that? No.
>> Is it the same? So, does Allah say does
Allah say in B that the Jew and the
Christian will be your rescue from
hellfire? Does he say that in B?
>> Yes.
>> Show me where it says that in B. Read
it. Read B. Read it out loud.
>> Says no Muslim would die, but Allah
would instead a Jew or Christian
hellfire.
>> Does he say that? Does he say that the
Jew and the Christian will be your
rescue?
>> For example, like
>> it will be your a Jew or Christian. So,
so I'll I'll ask it again.
Yeah. In their place, not your rescue.
Those are different. I understand this.
So, this is his problem. Notice allow me
to speak.
>> Can I speak? Can I Can I speak now?
Look, you got to do all this. It's It's
so weak, bro. So, this is the problem.
When you say the wording, now you're
talking over me. Now you're talking over
me. This is why I wasn't talking to you,
bro. No, I wasn't. So, now So, now can I
speak now? Can I speak now, fell? Thank
you. I appreciate it. So when he comes
here and says a particular wording is
weak, it's not talking about Muslim A or
B. It's really talking about D. Can I
finish?
Which one?
>> Because there's three.
>> One says that that is your rescue from
her fire. Another one says that this is
that that uh uh they will take your
stand. They will replace you in the
stand. Let me finish. Allow me to
finish.
>> But you don't let me finish.
>> You're you're panicking. I LET YOU
FINISH. I LET YOU ALL I LET YOU DO ALL
YOUR TALKING. If you're so confident,
let me finish.
>> I LITERALLY
>> LOOK, EVEN YOUR VOICE calming you down.
Let me finish.
>> Okay, that's cool. Let me finish.
>> All right. So, if you don't let me
finish, I'm going to continue talking to
these guys.
>> Let me finish.
>> All right. So, like I was saying, so
like I was saying, when he says that
there's a narration in Sah Muslim that's
weak, the question is which one? Because
Sah Muslim has three different
narrations of this hadith. Three
different ones. So when he says, "Excuse
me. Excuse me. I'm I'm talking to them.
Calm down. Your brother's trying to calm
you down. Relax." So when you say, "Oh,
uh, there's a narration in Sai Muslim
that's weak according to some where
others say it's Sah." Um, like, uh, uh,
what's what's the guy's name? Um,
>> sure. It's cool.
>> They're saying just one second.
>> Yeah. Well, exactly. I I understand. So,
the question is which wording? The
question is which wording cuz it ain't B
>> and it ain't A.
>> They don't argue that this that the
wording here is weak. So when they said
when he says here, oh it's the same
wording. Oh uh he just read the two
different hadith and like a he's
saying they're the same thing.
>> Okay.
>> So that's what it is. But this is what
it is when you be disrespectful. That's
what you get.
>> So yeah in a second. So according to
according to the hadith when it says
that no Muslim would die but Allah would
admit in hisstead. In whose state? Who
near this?
>> Answer the question,
>> bro.
>> In whostead?
>> Did you talk?
>> Whostead? Answer the question. You said
you would answer.
>> This is a This is a weak and I show you
scholars. Okay, I'm done with five, six,
seven. All right. Appreciate it. Can I
talk? So, it says in the Muslimstead, it
says in the Muslimstead that the Jew and
the Christian will take the place of the
Muslim. You're you're a child, bro.
You're belligerent. You're a child. I
don't want to talk to you. I want to
have a calm conversation with the guys.
You know, you're embarrassing yourself,
bro. You absolutely embarrassed
yourself. You absolutely embarrassed
yourself.
>> Talking now. I can't talk.
>> You absolutely embarrassed yourself.
>> And I answered the question.
>> No, you didn't.
>> Okay, let's let's let's do this again.
In whostead,
>> bro. This is
>> No answer again. No answer again.
>> Hey, brother.
>> He says answer the question when I say
>> no answer. No, you're theatric.
>> I'll give you another chance. Here's
your last chance. If you don't answer
right now, I'm done. I'm done talking to
you. The cops are looking at you.
>> In whose stand?
>> The cops are looking at you in I told
you.
>> So, no answer. You're done. I'm done
talking to you. I'm done talking. You're
a child. Please. Please give your phone.
You got
>> So, what's your what's your question,
bro?
>> That was cute, though. That was a cute
try.
>> I can't hear you over here.
>> That was a cute try, bro.
Hold on.
>> I know. I'm trying to talk to you.
>> No, it's my turn to talk.
>> I'm done talking to you. You're
belligerent. You're arrogant. You're
ignorant. You don't want a show
conversation. So, please.
>> That's why you got big. Okay, you got
it. You got it. You got it. Take care.
What's your question, bro?
>> The same hadith. Hold on.
>> Nobody's talking to you. Nobody's
listening to you. Nobody can hear you.
You don't know the difference of hadith.
Please walk away and go talk to someone
else.
He literally bakes. He doesn't know.
>> Take care of yourself. Bye.
>> He's like, he didn't say to
rescue. It says
>> bye. Thank you.
>> It doesn't say rescue. It says, bro, you
have no clue what you're talking about.
>> Thank you. What was your question?
>> Yo, yo, I'm not Yo, why are you stepping
over the hill? We tripping, bro. It's
not I'm trying to talk to your brothers
here.
>> Get out of here. It's my table.
>> Look, look at this. This is
embarrassing, bro.
>> This is embarrassing. Immature
embarrassment. But this is how it gets
when you don't know what you're talking
about. You get hyped. You get panicky.
You get anticely. This is how you act
when you have no answers. And you got to
follow us around. Followed us from the
other campus just to yell over it, bro.
>> So, what was your question? I'm trying
to talk to you.
>> Why are you not talking to me? I've been
trying to talk to you for five hours and
he doesn't want to talk to me. What's
your question, bro? That same question.
>> I'm trying to talk to you, but this
belligerent dude is trying is engaging
that. Yo, what is your response to that?
>> Do you want to come over here and talk?
>> I don't have a response. You're scared.
>> You're not allowed to go over there.
Okay, you're scared, right?
>> Yo, if this is how it is, man, we can't
talk to you.
>> That was cute. But if
>> So, while we got If you all you have is
this belligerent child, this
disrespectful arrogant is going to
be talking to you like this. This is
what it is. So, is the conversation
over? is dead.
>> Is the conversation over?
>> You need a defense. Do you have more to
say?
>> I'm I'm talking to you guys. Yes.
>> I mean,
>> I'm talking to you guys.
>> So, the wording the wording regarding
the
>> regarding regarding what hadith
>> the one that's
Oh, both. Show me where it says that
both. Show me where it says the wording
of B is weak.
>> Was it by?
>> Show me where it says that the wording
of B is weak. And it says it says the
narrated by Muslim are
>> which one? It says are blur.
>> No, no, it's not talking about all of
them. It's talking ABOUT ONE SPECIFIC
ONE. THAT'S why read the hadith and see
which one it's talking about. Read the
narration.
>> The one that was narrated by the one
that was by which one of them were
narrated. No. So which when he says the
one, which one is he talking about?
>> He doesn't say the one.
>> He doesn't say the one. He says the
other
thing that's like saying I'm gonna eat
tomatoes. Oh no.
>> So sah ain't sah anymore guys. Sah ain't
sah no more. Sah means weak now. Sah
means weak now.
>> Which in which one?
>> It says the one narrated by im Muslim.
Both these were narrated by Muslim.
>> Wait. So which one? Cuz he has multiple.
>> No, he doesn't say which. He doesn't say
which one is he talking about other
plural. There are other hadith which
indicate the wording narrated by im
Muslim from yada yada yada are weak.
WHICH ONE?
WHICH ONE? Cuz that's not the one that's
translated. So which
and and not and notice this. It says
there are other bro you don't got to
control. Notice how it says
do you know do you know what it means to
say that they're suggested? So look,
let's read it again. There are other
hadith which indicate the wording
narrated by im Muslim from was brought
down from people of God. It doesn't say
that people talking about this which is
revealed.
>> Yeah, it's talking about both.
>> How do where does it say that?
>> Brother I'm I'm ask I'm going ask you
the same thing. I'm ask you the same
thing. When it says when it says notice
how they didn't translate this when it
says there are other which brother you
don't you don't control you don't you
don't control I'm talking to him please
I'm talking to him so when it says that
there are other hadith which indicate
the wording by imm
what does that say about 26
>> what does that say can you translate
that
>> both of them are 2767 can you translate
>> both of them are Muslim 2767
It doesn't even say that. And this is
and this is how you see the ignorance
and the arrogance. When you're too
ignorant and you come bolstering, you
come loud. You come forcing yourself.
No, I'm talking about you. When you have
a Muslim that is bold, that's loud,
that's arrogant, that can't have a
dialogue. This shows the panic because
he cannot even handle being challenged
with this what he said. So that's what
it is.
>> That's what it is.
>> Oh, did did we was I yelling at you? No,
you're Was I forcing my way in front of
you? Was I Was I cover? Was I taking
your face? Was I doing that to you? Look
at that. So, this guy has to control you
and the conversation in order to stop
the conversation. That's how it is.
That's what it is. You're weak, bro.
You're weak. You're weak. You're weak.
You're weak. You're weak. Did I not just
try to So, I'm I'm going to give you a
chance to be to be objective here. Did I
not just try to talk? He can't see me.
Who Who's the one yelling right now? I'm
not here. You're both here.
>> Oh, we're both yelling. So, I I can't
trust you, right? Cuz cuz you're Cuz you
can't even be honest enough to hold your
brother accountable.
>> When I was talking to you guys, were we
yelling?
>> No.
>> When I was talking to you guys, did we
let each other speak?
>> Just answer, please. If you can answer,
please. Did Did we let each other speak?
>> So, there was not one point in the
conversation. And and and did and when
we noticed that, did I stop? And when
you noticed that, did you stop? The
Bible speak.
>> So notice that in the conversation you
and I have decor. You see that? Do you
see how this dude is all up in your ear
pulling you trying to control the
conversation? This shows childish
behavior. So we don't talk to children.
I'm willing to talk to two young men
adults
and you respond in the same light as
him.
>> I'm not responding in the same language.
I'm choosing not to talk to the child.
>> A
>> Yeah. He's a He came
disrespectful. That's what he is.
>> Okay. Is that not
>> No, it's not. It's It's It's being real.
>> I I said I didn't say idiot. I
said Several times.
>> Yeah. Absolutely. That's what he's
That's what he's doing.
>> No, I'm not. I'm not controlling the
conversation. I'm not pulling you away.
I'm not pulling your face. I can I can
do that. I can do this. I can do that. I
can do all that. Right.
>> Stop making excuses and call them out.
If you're not going to make it, if
you're going to continue to make
excuses, we can't talk, bro.
>> Look, look, they were allowed that
you're bringing
a little too. You're behaving the same
way.
>> Well, the cops are looking at we got we
could be chill.
>> The cops are looking at
>> You're not We We had our chill
conversation, brother. If you ever want
to talk, you can step forward. We can
have our conversation like we were
having, but if you're going to continue
to let him like just bully you, control
the conversation, we can't have a
conversation. He's too belligerent.
>> My name is Avery. What's it called? Um,
we came to the decision. If you don't
want to talk to me,
>> oh my goodness.
>> Then I would tell you to leave the table
kindly. Okay.
>> Yeah.
>> We want you to leave the table.
>> This when I talk, you talk to everyone
else. Make it look like I'm doing a
crazy.
>> Notice we're doing it again.
>> And and Yeah. And I was being
respectful.
>> No. Not Notice when we was talking, it
was calm. It was respectful. The cops
were
>> and all of this. No, you were the one
screaming. You were the one coming over
yelling.
>> You said you said I'm so the cops start
looking at you.
>> You're doing it again. fighting for my
attention. You don't want to talk. You
could be done, but I'm still talking to
them. I am talking to manager on this
table.
>> He's not knowledgeable.
>> I'm not saying he's not knowledgeable.
>> You just did it. So you guys, I see it.
When they don't get their way, they try
to be controlling. At least one of them.
Let me give a shout out to the other
brothers, uh, the other Muslim brothers
who are respectful, who are engaging,
who are in being intellectually honest.
But we have one of them who followed us
over here from the other campus just to
disrupt the conversation and to get
security to get us away from their table
because I would ignore him and his
belligery, his arrogance, his moral, his
uh his idiocy. So this is what happens
when Muslims don't go get this way and
they're all getting cooked at the wrong
table. This is all we do, man. We just
read.
>> All right, we'll catch you on the next
one. Peace.
>> Stop lying.
Stop crying.
Stop whining.
You got me dying. Stop crying.
Stop crying.